This book may be of great interest to many people...
...because today's top leaders share their valuable learning journeys and experiences...
...that they have had during their lives.
Famous people in management and organizational development worldwide...
...talk about their vulnerabilities and reveal how learning from their experiences...
...has formed their personalities, careers, and style of leadership.
One prominent contributor talks about how physiotherapy after a childhood illness...
...transformed his life and gave him a purpose.
A further story is about the power of perception...
...and how one tollbooth worker's view of life made his working environment a happy one.
Yet, another celebrity contributes memories of a depressed and friendless childhood...
...and how one of his teachers changed his life forever.
The book is compiled into thematic sections like "Developing Self-knowledge"...
...and "Seeing Yourself as Others Do"...
...together with discussion questions for the readers.